[Music]  my name is douglas kennedy and i have  been at fox news channel for 25 years i  think fox news had a culture uh that  said  we're going to take chances that other  networks  we're not willing to take he wants a  government investigation into the  anti-depressant industry i had obtained  internal documents from clinical trials  of a drug that was supposed to prevent  depression but was in fact causing  suicide i had no doubt that the  medication did this what was amazing at  that point was that most of cable news  was getting most of their advertising  from the pharmaceutical industry and we  were exposing the pharmaceutical  industry this was an incredible act of  courage that no other network  would have taken and all the lives that  were saved because of that story would  not have been saved